next week we'll celebrate earth day and
for many that means a visit to some of
the wild places where the planet's
natural beauty has been preserved in
many cases those lands and their
inhabitants are thriving not because
they're left idle but because they're
used by hunters and fishermen who are
responsible for the majority of state
conservation funding and are deeply
committed to keeping these areas
undeveloped and well cared for
i had the chance to head into the wild
to talk to some of these everyday
conservationists about the important
role they play and the future of our
nation's most scenic spaces
in one of the most picturesque parts of
america home to two national parks an
array of wildlife come on
that was a good looking bird and the
foothills of the blackfoot river i want
that thing coming straight over the back
of your head
okay montana mountain man land tawny
tried to teach a novice set set like i'm
going to tell you that how to fly fish
good cast dude holy cow
not an easy feat i'm a fly fisher woman
you got that right
but as founder of back country hunters
and anglers he's used to it anybody can
do this this water belongs to everybody
in america they have public access to
this water this fishing hole was a
favorite of his parents conservation
lobbyists trying to preserve the native
west
when you are out in the outdoors like we
are today get an appreciation that when
we had that eagle that was up in the
trees or you know when we catch a fish
ultimately or haven't when we catch a
fish yeah we got a fish oh we got a
little baby fish it's like you have a
connection now to this river that not if
you weren't fishing you won't
necessarily have and so when people are
out there then they want to make sure
that is there for them and for future
generations and so if your inability to
fish or to hunt the idea conservation
goes away pretty quickly like we have to
be participants in this whole system
tawny knows is both hunter and gun owner
his status as protector of the
environment might come into question but
he believes all three can co-exist it
really is the bambi effect how do you
tell someone who comes from like
that perspective that hunting is a bad
thing that what you're doing something
that actually helps the environment so
you bring up bambi are there some
hunters like that absolutely but they're
ostracized like you know that idea of
of take and not being connected to those
animals
you know as a hunter it's regulated
scientifically managed and so this isn't
like i can go shoot as many deer as i
want you know there's rules and
regulations around that i'm required to
eat those animals and i would say that
feeding my family that connection i have
to that animal i'm in their habitat when
i'm hunting
i'm not an observer i'm a participant
and so i know more about them and have
such an appreciation for them and so i
want to make sure that those animals are
going to be out there forever and
they're going to thrive that symbiotic
relationship began over a century ago
with president theodore roosevelt an
outdoorsman and trophy hunter he also
witnessed its detrimental impact
realizing our nation's natural resources
were in limited supply
so while setting aside 240 million acres
to establish our national park system he
also helped end the practice of market
hunting it is so beautiful setting the
tone for our conservation ethos
how awesome this is that we get to be
the caretakers right now and play a part
in all this public lands it's available
to everybody we're playing a role that's
really been around for about 150 years
by 1937 the hunting community lobbied
congress to tax the industry and today
that legacy funds 60 percent of
state-based conservation efforts through
the sale of hunting and fishing licenses
as well as excise taxes on gear guns and
ammunition i paid for my little fishing
license how did i put into
the conservation effort when you pay for
your fishing license the money for your
license goes to the fish and wildlife
service
martha williams leads the agency and
then that goes out to states and
partners to make sure
that we know
the fish populations can be healthy
to make sure that they're boat ramps and
there's access for you to be able to get
on the river or the stream it makes sure
that you have hopefully a really great
experience
williams acknowledges hunters pay far
more into the system they're just four
percent of the population but their
numbers have been on the decline down
from 17 million in the mid-1970s to 11.5
million in 2016. that is until the
pandemic turned america's attention back
to the great outdoors what we saw across
the board in all states was more and
more people getting outside more and
more people using our public lands what
are you seeing in terms of the money
brought in to conserve public lands we
have seen a continuing increase in the
excise taxes we've seen more money come
in from ammunition sales from hunting
and tackle gear
we've seen those revenues increase
but that trend may not be permanent
isn't there though a concern that as
fewer hunters participate in hunting
season that that may affect your bottom
line i mean yeah in the conservation
effort yes it does are you looking at
ways to
change this this system we are always
looking at other
ways to fund conservation in this
country
beyond hunting and fishing excise taxes
and then
add to that
always wanting to build and bring more
people into hunting and fishing so that
it continues so basically
you're widening you're you're absolutely
we want to widen the tent widening that
tent she says might include levying a
so-called backpack tax on recreational
users of public lands hikers bikers and
kayakers others believe the federal
government should foot more of the bill
but congress has yet to act on the
recovering america's wildlife act for
now you're paying the price of keeping
our forests and our rivers and our
streams healthy gladly we're paying the
price gladly we're paying the price sets
and we wear that on our sleeve but it's
not enough and so how are we going to
continue to fund our wildlife agencies
that are in charge of managing these
species how we're going to continue to
fund the restoration and conservation
needs to happen but what i love even
more is this idea of people that don't
hunt and fish wearing that on their
sleeve like we do i love that
yeah not everybody likes the idea of a
backpack test chief among them rei the
outdoor outfitter they say you know they
put in along with hunters and fishermen
they put in about 125 billion right
the federal government doesn't put
anywhere near that much money they just
collect it and then pass it on and they
say that that's where the money needs to
come from that the federal government
should share more of the pie in itself
coming from our general operating fund
so
we'll see what happens but
congress has yet to act
interesting thanks michelle